- On this episode,
Erik Wahl stops by and
we get artistic and thoughtful.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 243
of The #AskGaryVee Show
and I'm super excited.
Another guest, Erik.
- Dude, you do that so good.
- Actually, I've
been rusty lately,
but since I did it
recently, I remembered
what the title was.
You've got a
big Sharpie with you.
Erik Wahl, welcome to the show.
Thrilled to see you, my man.
- Thank you kindly.
Appreciate the
opportunity to be here.
- I'm excited because
you've got a big book launch.
We've got a call-in show.
You are a killer of the arts.
I mean, people
who are seeing this,
you might have seen the
version you've made for myself.
In episodes of DailyVee.
You are a very talented dude
that I've gotten to
know in the last year or so,
and I'm excited to
introduce you to the audience.
So for the people that
don't know who you are,
how do you sum yourself up?
- I am a disruptive strategist.
So, I'm a performance
artist who speaks
on the
corporate lecture circuit.
I'm also an author.
Flying around,
doing 100 shows a year
for the last 12 years in a row.
Sharing about
disruption, how to innovate,
how to differentiate
from the competition,
how to embrace the
future of business.
But it's a very niche
market, so it's all corporate.
Conferences, sales events, but
I don't do many public shows,
so I'm not a household name.
I'm invisible to pop culture.
- Because you've been
more into a B2B strategy.
- Exactly.
- Right.
- Speaking to corporate.
- So how did you get there?
Did you come, I'm going to
assume, just knowing your vibe,
you came up as
an artist and then,
did you stumble into that world?
Or did you go the other way?
Help me.
- Negative.
I'm a former,--
- See?
- I'm a former suit.
- That's why you
don't assume, people.
Sorry, Stephan.
- I have a very
logical, linear background.
I went to school, went
to, got a job out of school
as a partner in a firm.
- Jesus.
- Did that for eight years,
then had an early
mid-life crisis, and,
- So at 30?
- At 30.
- I did too, a little bit.
- Yeah?
And that's where
I found the arts.
I didn't care about
creativity in the arts
because there
was no money in it.
- Yeah.
- You can't make it.
There's no ROI.
- So what kind of kid were you?
So you drawn, you were,--
- I was an athlete.
- You were an athlete?
- Athlete and I
was an alpha dog,
so divide and conquer, kick ass.
If it was in school,--
- What did you play?
- I was a wrestler.
I also, you know,
football, baseball, basketball.
- Where did you grow up?
- In Seattle, Washington.
- Okay, are you a Seahawks fan?
No?
- I'm a recovering Seahawks,
so I, because I
watched it with my dad,--
- Yeah.
- I was a Seahawks fan,
I was Mariner fan.
- You loved Steve Largent?
(both laugh)
- You know who Steve Largent is?
- Listen, we're old.
- Yeah.
- I do.
- Jim Zorn.
- I'm 41 years old.
- Jim Zorn
through to Steve Largent.
Sherman Smith is
who carried the pill.
Dan Doornik,--
- Oh, you?
In Seattle, people that I know.
- You're bringin' it.
- And I also was there,
- But I remember
Warner and David Kreig.
I'm like, I remember those
mid-'80s Seahawks teams.
- And I remember Al Toon.
- Yep, that's my boy.
- I remember, I don't
remember Joe Namath.
- Yeah, me neither.
- That, my dad told me.
- So,
- My dad told me about it.
- So Seattle athlete.
- Yep.
- Alpha dog, win, win, win.
- Go into job, get a
good job, duh, duh, duh.
- Win, win, win, there.
- 30 years old, freak out.
- Dot-com bomb, I got flattened.
- Got it.
- So I,--
- Why, did you put
your money into the market?
- Everything, yeah.
So I was, because I,--
- Was that?
- Yeah because you,--
- Because Seattle, mmm.
- At that age, well, I didn't,
all I knew is that when
I graduated from college,
everything you touch didn't,--
- Which was what year?
- '93.
- Okay, so you're
five years older than me.
Go ahead.
- Everything you
touch turns to gold.
You buy InfoSpace at
five and in seven days,
it was at 75, so I knew,--
- This is interesting timing.
- I was going to, and
it actually, you know,
I thought I was going
to retire at age 27, 28.
- So you were making
good money at a corporate job,
taking the money and
investing in the market
and making a killing.
- Killing for me.
- For you, correct.
- For me, it was
- I'm not even trying,
but you know, listen.
Buying stocks at
five that go to 170,
even if you put in $10,000,
you're making real money.
- Plus, the rush
of how that feels.
I'm so smart.
- So, what, were you?
Listen, it's
funny because I, again,
I keep yelling at all
these kids on Instagram
that life's too good right now.
When this crashes,
shit's going to get weird.
Were you, I forgot about this.
This actually reminded me.
Were you at a place
where you had your job,
but you were
struggling to even focus on it
because you kept
looking at Yahoo Finance
and watching the money?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Refresh, refresh.
- Guys,
- Refresh.
- Doo, doo, doo, doo.
- You were watching your stocks
and every time my stock went up,
I was like, a
little bit happier.
I was a little bit smarter.
I was a little bit,--
- You thought you
were a real genius?
- I was closer to retirement,
but when my stock went down,
I started to get pissed.
(Gary laughs)
I started to maybe
not treat people as well.
And it was like losing a sale,
was when my stock went down.
And it then, it
all went down and,--
- Are we talking about 2000?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it burned.
- And so, I got destroyed.
- Hammered.
- I got destroyed.
- So what happened?
- It was like a shark attack.
- Were you
married at this point?
- Yeah, to that,
- Yeah, I know.
I know, I see her.
- To that beautiful
woman right there. 22 years.
- So wait, you like, literally,
it was April, right?
It was April, so what?
You just come
home and like, "Fuck"?
- Well, it felt like that,
but it lasted a lot longer.
So the suffering, first of all,
you lose everything,
then you think
about everything you lost
and then you just walk
around the house at night
because you can't sleep
because everything that I was
was wrapped up--
- In the success of that.
- In the success
of that and the money,
my security.
- Your self-worth, yeah.
- I was addicted to security.
- Redaction of
security of those finances.
- Yeah, and so
when that was taken away
and they said,
I basically had to start over
at ground zero.
That was really depressing.
- With three little kids.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- And no money.
- Did you have, yeah.
And what, did you have mortgages
and all that good stuff?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- So what happened?
(Erik laughs)
- So,--
- So wait, did you
lose the consultant,
did you lose the
job you had, too?
- I left the job
because that dried up.
- Because you
were just like, yeah.
- Yeah, what I did was,
I brokered entertainment
and so, at that time,
- Well, this is
the thing that, again,
like listen, we're
going a little somber start.
It will get better.
(Erik laughs)
But I want
everybody to pay attention
because you guys know
that I've been on this kick
that this good
times can't last forever.
It's not only that
you don't get paid $8,000
to take a photo in your
Instagram with a fucking tea
or thing like that.
You also actually
lose your other job.
So like, who else?
So, somebody making a
buck 30 a year right now,
24 years old doing
sponsored posts on Instagram
around clothing brands,
and fruit, and protein shakes,
it's not only that you lose that
because the
brands dollars shred up
when the economy goes soft,
it's that when you
then go to get a job,
those jobs aren't there either.
Like, it goes from here to here.
- And you're balancing,
I was balancing my ego
in this as well.
So my ego,--
- Well, what you think
is wrapped up and when you
say in your Instagram profile
you're an influencer and
you're traveling to Ibiza
and Coachella, and
telling all your friends
that you're making $180,000,
$400,000, $1 million a year.
- They expect that
of you in perpetuity,
and if you can't
showcase it all the time,
all the sudden
you start to feel less.
I felt less.
It was a very difficult time.
So let's bounce from there.
- Let's go.
- That's where I,
- I want to stay there
the whole time,
just so everybody knows
because I want you
fuckers to actually understand
what the fuck
we're talking about,
but we'll bounce for now.
- It, it--
- We'll go to this clip
in 16 months
when the world melts.
Go ahead.
- There you go.
(group laughter)
- So I needed to find a reason
to get up in the morning.
I needed to
find a reason to go on
and I didn't want to go back
and try and build this business
from zero and try and
find what I want to do
with the rest of my life.
And so, I actually
found life with other artists.
Like, other people who
had suffered a little bit,
I could relate to them.
(Gary laughs)
And they started sharing,--
- Suffering artists like India.
- Starving artists.
- Yeah.
- And the reason it's a
cliche is because it's true.
Now India's work is unbelievable
and she's going to be
worth millions, but there's,
- I agree, I agree.
She doesn't know this,
but I own 49% of it
when she signed her contract.
(India laughs)
Sorry, India.
Go ahead.
- There's actually,--
- India, you need to show her.
You got to show her.
She hasn't been on The
#AskGaryVee Show in 100 years.
- Hi.
- [Gary] Alright.
- India!
- For two years.
- India and I have
worked closely here for a while.
- So go ahead.
- So I've realized that
gosh, a lot of these artists
actually aren't that happy,
even though they
have these philosophies,
they don't have any income.
They don't have any,--
- Sure.
- money. They don't know how to
build traction or build a brand,
and so,--
- Well, they're probably
like India, they get
happiness out of complaining
and being starving
(Erik laughs)
and the negativity.
By the way, I'm that way too.
It's actually why, you
know, you want to hear this?
It's actually why I
really associate with that.
I like the pain of the process.
- Mhmmm.
- I really do, like, the
reason I keep fantasizing
about melting is I'm excited.
By the way, you think I'm
excited to fire 280 people
because a third of
our clients fire us?
You think that's
interesting to me?
You don't think I think
about that every day
in a world where we've
had nothing but growth?
I'm scared shitless of the
pain that's going to bring me.
Truth is, you have no options.
- The way things go.
If you're an artist
looking to build a brand,
I think there is a lot to learn.
That's what I
found is that artists
did not have
that grind of learning
how to amplify
their brand to scale.
How to push
their genius out there,
and so that's where I come--
- So you were business-y,
went to art, and then
went back to
business-y around art.
- Right.
- I love that.
- And this time is
when I started to create.
I'd never painted before, but
it was so fascinating to me.
- You're so good at it!
No really, he is.
- [DRock] He's very intelligent.
- Are you fascinated by that?
One thing I tell
a lot of people is,
people ask me, what's
my passion Gary, right?
And I'm like, well if
you never had a hot dog,
would you know if
you liked eating hot dogs?
Did you find it,
were you confused
that you were good at it?
- Good is a relative term.
I sucked when I started,
but I loved the process.
I loved the idea of creating,
I loved the idea
of getting better.
Painting was
just where it kind of
opened up and I got branded
as a graffiti artist early on,
partly because
I loved it so much,
I loved their philosophy,
I loved street artists,
and also I started doing it
and hanging out with them.
But I also started
landscape painting,
figure drawing, writing poetry,
doing photography,
so that was the
gateway drug to understanding
creativity as a whole.
And creativity is not
just painting or graffiti,
it's a way of life,
it's an energy.
- It's a mindset.
So that's why I took
it not only into writing
and into sculpture
but also into business,
because business is
all about being creative.
- Of course.
- Marketing, strategy...
- So actually now I'm really
deep into the vortex of this.
So you start making shit, right?
You've got three
kids at home and the wife.
What happens?
Give me a quick five second
2000 to 2005, like,
what happened?
- I started writing all
these ideas that artists
had the genius but no
discipline to how to get
their message to scale.
Businesses had this
incredible discipline
but no disruptive
thinking or curiosity,
so that's where I
wrote a presentation about
how to merge the two.
I called it The Art of Vision,
started painting onstage,
started cranking rock music.
- How did you
get your first gig?
- Marketing. Hustling.
My wife and I created
a manufactured brochure.
We taped a presentation,
so we asked a local college,
hey can we come and
deliver a presentation for free.
- How much did they pay you?
- We got paid zero.
And we also paid a film
crew to come and film us.
- Negative!
- And make it look like,
make it look like this is
something that it isn't.
- How many presentations
did you give for free
in the early days?
- Fortunately, and I know
where you're going with this...
- But that's
okay, I want your truth,
I don't want you to
appease my strategy.
- Yeah, I did probably three.
- No, no you have to understand.
Enormous amounts of
people feel like that's
three too many.
- If you want to be
a professional speaker,
you should be doing
hundreds of present--
- If you want to be
a professional anything
that nobody else
wants to pay you for,
you should do it for free.
That's your
only way of doing it.
- When I first spoke, I sucked!
My wife was super...
- Disappointed in you?
- She was super supportive.
(woman laughs)
- She's like "You suck"!
- Somehow she
was able to muster,
instead of saying "You
suck", she still was able
to say, "Let's go Hon".
So I felt
affirmed, I'm like okay--
- But she's more
glass half full, right?
And you're more
glass half empty.
- I would say so.
- I know you guys, not
that you're so horrible,
but I mean she is
a little bit more,
like her natural
reaction is a little bit
more positive.
- She's my Yoko Ono.
So I'm this kind of
confused John Lennon.
I've got ideas but
insecure about putting them
out there.
That's the truth.
She's always been
behind me and pushing
that out there,
like "You know what?
"I think this is
gonna be awesome.
"You know what?
They're gonna go for this".
And so I had a lot of
support and encouragement
early on from her,
and I ended up doing
a presentation.
She hustled for
me to speak to some
American healthcare association,
kind of a national meeting,
and inside there's 50
state associations, so--
- And that blew it up!
- It's kind of
like hitting the lotto.
- That was the moment.
- [Woman] That was the moment,
and you just kind
of learn as you go.
- Yeah a hundred percent.
- [Woman] What's the
best way is you start
big and you go
backwards, you reverse engineer.
- Hundred percent.
We're about to
get into a phone call.
I want to do two things
before we get there, Andy.
Oh you're Facebook, Instagram,
start putting your phone...
Oh you're doing Facebook!
Instagram, sorry.
Facebook Live is doing
the phone numbers this time.
Please post your phone numbers
and we will call somebody.
- I wanna make one
connection really quick.
- You're gonna be
able to do that for sure.
I got two other
things before we do calls.
Go ahead, you start.
- Okay. You gave a
presentation in Dublin
called Clouds and Dirt?
- Yes.
- That is the
spark and the grind.
It is the idea and execution.
- Wait you just wrote
the Clouds and Dirt book
that I've been
wanting to write one day?
I'm very upset right now!
- I beat you to market.
- Is that the spiel?
- That is exactly
it, and that's why
I brought Rodin's Thinker,
because he's a man
of great muscularity,
so it's not just this sage,
he's a doer, and so he's
kind of been my little mascot
that I've been
bringing around with me.
- This one.
- Yes, the Heisman trophy.
- And so this, why don't
we study for another second
the book.
You've written several books?
- This is my second
major published release.
- And did some direct
to consumer stuff before,
but you feel like
this is your second book.
- This is my second baby.
- How do you feel
that process has been?
This is your second book.
How do you
compare it to your first?
What do you
think you did better?
What's different, da da da...
- The writing
process was similar
in that I love it.
I love the grind of writing.
- You love writing?
- I love writing.
- I hate writing.
I don't write.
- What I don't
like is the marketing.
The fact that I've gotta like,
Hey everyone...
I actually don't care--
- You hate selling?
- I know you love selling--
- No, no, be careful.
I've said this, some of
you that really know me,
I actually hate microselling.
The way I like selling
is giving so much value,
and building so much brand,
that it's sold before,
I hate selling.
I actually decided not
to raise a fund last year.
I was raising a big fund,
Vayner Capital, a new fund.
And I stopped 'cause
I so disliked asking
people for money.
- I hear you.
- I hate it. I hate selling.
I hate it.
- I hate the fact that
this is tipped up like this
like we're trying to pimp it.
- I agree. No, no--
- I would prefer--
- Like, yeah.
- Let's put those over there.
Let's just talk--
- I agree.
- We'll let the
thinker stand in--
- I agree. I get it.
I mean, every time
when I'm on book tour
and I'm doing
something like this,
they're like,
"Why don't you tell us
"why they should buy the book?"
I'm like, "They shouldn't!"
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
- Don't buy it!
- I'm not interested in going
through chapter by chapter
or anything about that book.
It's the brand.
That's one channel of my brand.
- By the way, I'm thinking
about calling it "Crushing It."
Not "Crushed It."
I'm writing my next
one called "Crushing It."
- Okay.
- It's a follow up.
And the process, but I
do it totally different.
I have a ghost writer.
I'm recording it,
like doing interviews,
sliding down icy driveways
in Colorado while I do it,
but I was curious how
everybody's different process.
I'm always curious
about the second time.
- So, mine is a verbal vomit.
I write every single day.
That's what I do.
That's how I process thought.
That's how I think.
So, I write, write, write.
It's called a verbal vomit.
And then I send it to editors.
(Gary murmurs) And
like, Random House.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And they're incredible,
because they put it in
bite-sized chunks
where consumers are like,
"Oh, yeah. That makes sense.
"Oh yeah, That makes sense."
But when I think,
I'm just writing.
So that's what it is.
- You have an ungodly
amount of 20 to 25-year-old
entrepreneurs,
wannabe entrepreneurs,
and we have the full gamut,
but growth on
Instagram for me has translated
to a much younger audience.
What do you want to tell
those characters right now?
Let's do our first phone call.
What's on your
mind for that demo?
I know this is generalizing.
- That structure
creates freedom.
So, that's kind of
the paradox of creativity
or innovation.
That discipline and
routine and hard work
is what makes way
for constant creativity.
And then, of course, patience.
- You agree with that?
- I'm living that.
It's more than just agreeing.
- It's not something
that came natural to you
in your younger age?
- Patience?
(woman laughter)
No, no.
I'm an alpha dog.
- But I am, and
patience comes very easy to me.
- That's awesome.
- I do both.
- And that's awesome for you.
I've learned more
patience in the last 12 months
than I've had to
endure my entire life--
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Before we go
into this phone call,
I'm sorry there.
In the last 12 months?
- Yeah. Should I
get comfy on the couch?
- Yeah.
- Do the psychology thing?
- You intrigued me before we--
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
Tell me that.
- That I thought my
brand was gonna launch.
I thought that I've
done the 10, 12 years
of hard ass work, slaving
away doing 100 shows a year--
- Mmhmm.
- Logging 250,000 miles--
- That as soon as
you went out, weirdly,
and did the
videos and all this--
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Dude. Shit, man.
That makes me so,
so, I don't know
if you know this,
but I have a TV show coming.
- I do.
- I'm convinced it is
not gonna be the thing
that people think it's gonna be.
It's Apple,
it's tens of millions
of dollars in marketing.
I think my ecosystem
thinks it's gonna be the moment
that I become
massively mainstream famous
and I already know that
it's not going to be that.
It'll be another piece.
- Mhmmm.
- But the
punchline is, it happens.
Simon Cowell, it happened.
It happens.
But I get it, man.
And I think
about it all the time.
The amount of times
this was gonna be the thing
that changes my career.
Remember Facebook video?
We had the inside
track on Facebook video.
Like, "This is
gonna be the thing!"
You know?
Like the other thing were
working on at the same time?
It's never the thing.
- I've gone
through a lot of suffering
to learn how to be patient,
to realize this will
take time on setbacks.
This too shall pass.
And all of those
are building resiliency
for wherever this thing goes.
And I don't know that
there is such thing as,
you say there's no such thing
as an overnight success,
but I wonder Malcolm Gladwell's
tipping point.
I'm waiting for that.
'Cause I feel like I've
done a lot of this backfill.
When does it tip?
When do you, "Ah! That was
sweet. That was the moment."
- So, I think
the question becomes,
"Are you able to
reframe your brain into
"that same place when you
were learning how to create?"
- Mhmmm.
- Yeah.
- You need to figure out how
much do you love this journey
and how you actually
change it to love it more
if you're yearning
for the tipping point.
I would tell you that I'm
sitting here psychoanalyzing
myself in parallel
to you and saying,
"Or am I secretly
hopeful that the Apple show
"won't work so big?"
Because I do love the grind.
I like losing.
Let me give you an example.
Tony Robbins was
here the other day.
- Yep.
- Right?
- I saw it.
10,000 viewers on Facebook.
- Yep, right.
- That was insane.
- Yep. Ready for this?
Ungodly amounts of
comments that I suck shit
because I
interrupt when I interview.
You would not
believe how much I love that.
I love when people
call out my shortcomings.
Perceived shortcomings!
Tony Robbins has eight
trillion interviews out there.
If you wanna go watch
or listen to an interview
where the person
doesn't interrupt them?
Mazel Tov.
I've got my style of my show.
It's free.
And I need to do it my way,
but it was funny.
I read them all.
- Yeah.
- During my little
pockets over the weekend,
I read them all.
All of them.
Every Facebook and
YouTube comment that says,
"Shut up, Gary. What the fuck?
"You're a douchebag. I hate you.
"You suck shit."
And I'm like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
(mimics eating)
More.
I love the process of losing
in a world where I'm alpha
and want to win
more than anything.
- I'm still learning that.
I am emotional.
I'm an artist.
I look at trollers or haters.
- Yes.
- And I'm like (groans).
- Yeah, to me, I pet
their little, fluffy hair
and go, "I'm listening to you."
By the way, I'm empathetic.
This is live.
This is super live.
Super no-edited.
It's not the only
thing I do in my life.
I'm not a professional
podcaster that makes
one fucking video once a week
and sit cozy in my
booth and have unlimited time
and it's the only fucking
thing I'm doing that day.
Sorry, was that--
- It's a channel--
(laughter)
- But--
- Oh my word!
- I do think that the
battle scars are attractive.
- They're what make
the joys that much higher.
So, I don't know that
success would feel as good
if you didn't feel
the pain along the way.
- I think when
I'm listening to you--
- [DRock] Brendon Marshall
just texted me and said,
"You interrupt a lot."
- Brandon Marshall did.
I love Brandon, but
now I don't care about
Brandon Marshall's feedback
because he's not a Jet anymore.
Brandon, you only have
so much weight with me.
- That's the
Jet's wide receiver,
for anyone who
doesn't know that.
That's cool, hey
Brandon, what's up?
- It's my natural feeling,
I go fast, I anticipate,
and I know it's not
enjoyable to watch at all times,
and I'm empathetic
and I do apologize,
but I just can't not be me.
And I think this
goes back to where
I was actually going with this,
which is the
greatest thing to hack is
figure out what parts
don't make the journey exciting
and either fix
them or cut them out
cause you lose otherwise.
- And to love the journey.
Like I realize at
this point in my career,
if I don't love what I'm doing,
(phone rings)
I'm not gonna grind at it,
so I love the hard work,
I do too.
(phone rings)
- Who is this?
- [Andy] Blake.
- [Blake] Hello.
- Blake, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Erik Wahl.
- [Blake] Get out of here.
- You made it Blake.
Where you from and
what's your question?
- [Blake] Wow, from Harrisburg,
Hershey, Pennsylvania,
chocolate-town USA
- Very nice.
- What's your name,
your name's Blink?
- Blake
- Blake.
Dude, my great, great
grandfather is Carlton Hershey,
invented the
Hershey bar long ago.
- The hell we doing here?
- So, shout out (crosstalk)
shouldn't there be
some royalties, right?
No, so anyway, cool,
I'm glad you're
calling from Hershey, PA.
- Blake, let's do it.
- [Blake] Sure,
well you talk a lot about
documenting the journey,
and you know,
I was trying to figure out,
the chicken or the egg here.
You know you talk
about starting and just doing
and going for it,
but then you talk about
how you didn't start talking
until you actually built,
you know, built a
business and built brand
and built awareness, but you
were quiet for quite some time.
So Gary, the chicken or the egg?
Which one do we do when we
try to build a personal brand?
- I'm glad you asked that,
because there's a very strong
clarification here that you'll
give to the whole audience
if they're confused and I can
see how they'd be confused.
I would've started documenting
the Wine Library journey,
but I wouldn't have at 22,
come out and said
I was a business expert
because I hadn't successfully
built a huge business,
so I would have
documented being,
"Hey guys, this is
22-year-old GaryVee,
"I think that I'm going
to be really successful
"because for the
last eight years,
"I've been
selling baseball cards,
"I've been in my dad's
business, I think got this,
"the internet's going
to be big, you'll see it."
So I would have been
documenting my truth when I say
I didn't come out
and talk until I did,
as an authority worthwhile
of writing business books
that I thought
people should have followed,
and so that's the clarification.
I would have
documented the early days
of my entrepreneurship.
What happened
instead was, I became,
I felt comfortable
coming out as an authority
because I had serious
business success at that point.
Does that make sense?
- [Blake] Yeah,
I understand that.
- So, I think you can
choose one or the other.
I would recommend
the documenting,
because if you're willing to
do it, the upside is extreme.
It gives you another
place where you might
be able to be successful
in or I'll for example,
I think Wine Library would
have done a lot more revenue,
if there were also
tens of thousands of people
following my journey
of building the store,
they would have come and visited
because they would have thought
the 25-year-old punk kid
was interesting and intriguing,
so it would have had
greater reach along the way.
- I want to also say, Blake,
I think you learn
a lot my documenting.
So just by the
process of documenting,
your mind is
working differently than
if you're just on
to the next product.
- What happened when you--
- Documenting--
- So, you started
documenting behind the wall,
I know it's
ideated across the way,
it's like what were
the biggest eye openers
when you started doing
the vlog in your world.
- That I sucked at it.
That I knew I was
good live on stage
when I could see the
whites of people's eyes,
and I could adjust,
but behind the camera,
when someone said,
"Action," or "Now you're on,"
I would tense up and
I would become less authentic.
So for me, it was just
massaging through the fact
that I'm not that
strong yet at being on camera.
- Did winning in artistry
and getting better at that
give you like a quiet confidence
in the back of your head
because you solved that thing?
- No, it was a hook.
Art was more therapy,
I use art in the presentations
because people think it's cool.
But for me, it's a
sanctuary back in my studio
just to grow, but
it's also documenting,
that's why I write, to document.
- Blake, I think
the key is always
reverse engineering yourself.
I think the fact that we're
capable of today's technologies
to document is really cool.
To be very frank with you,
one thing that I
also want to throw out is,
I think people are
underestimating
the documentation
of their lives and the
impact on their families.
I would tell you, no question,
the coolest thing
from documenting all this
and what I'm doing,
is the amount of content
my great, great-grandkids are
going to have in watching me,
and seeing the similarities
in their DNA and me.
Like it just cool, like having,
I don't have a
lot of family photos.
I know nothing about my two,
when I tell you I know nothing
about my two grandfathers,
I know nothing.
And so, like, I
think there's some cool,
the documenting is a
lot cooler than you think,
just from that part, let
alone the business impact
it has in the short term.
- We also talk, we opened the
show kind of talking about
Ibiza and the couple
hundred grand and private jets
and that's one thing for
Instagram and social media,
but to actually see
people who aren't winning yet,
to watch the process,
the challenge,
that documenting
I think is as interesting,
if not more interesting
that the actual bling bling.
- So Blake, I think you could
document the journey now,
and that would be cool
and it has it's upside,
or if it's more
interesting for you,
you put your head
down for a decade,
and if you want to
come out as an expert,
you come out after
you've already won,
cause it's a lot
more fun to talk shit
once you've
accomplished something.
- [Blake] Exactly,
I'm trying to do both,
so I appreciate that.
I knew you also
said that, you know,
instead of putting
like CEO in your profile,
put like "aspiring artist"
or something like that,
so how do you build credibility
if you're aspiring while trying.
- You don't, you
don't deserve credibility
if you haven't accomplished.
- [Blake] Okay.
- You may, you might
become fascinating to somebody
with your bravado of
predicting your accomplishments,
but people are
trying to get credibility
before they've earned it,
and they think some way they
can create a facade for it,
and that's my
fucking problem with it,
because it's undermining you.
You may trick the 10% losers,
but you've lost
with the 10% winners.
- [Blake] I'm with you,
I'm with you.
Just want to make sure
I've got confirmation on it.
- No worries brother.
Let's move it along
because I know we're,
time limit constraints.
I don't want to get
yelled at for interrupting.
- If you're an aspiring artist,
don't race to commoditize.
Keep working the
brand building the brand,
you might lose
authenticity if you try
to commoditize too early.
So aspiring artist,
stay hungry, build the brand,
but don't, be careful
about when you turn
and try and
turn into a business,
because you could lose
some of your authenticity.
- 100%.
(phone ringing)
- [Andy] Randy.
- Randy?
- [Andy] I'm going
through exactly what it...
- Well this is right.
- [Andy] We'll see.
- Randy this is Gary,
Randy this is
Gary Vaynerchuck,
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Randy]
What's up GaryVee?
Shout out to DRock
first off, Mark and Gary.
(radio feedback on phone)
Oh my god, I'm gonna need
to turn this off real quick.
Alright, sorry,
sorry about that.
My question to
you is, I've created
what I believe to
be a high end brand.
It doesn't have a
whole lot of followers,
but it's hard for
me to position myself
to create another brand
that will help
support me through this.
Because I'm doing
photography and video,
which is why I
shouted out to everybody
that's using the Sonys there.
Like what should I do?
I've been doing
this for 10 years,
I haven't really gotten
a whole lot of traction.
I've been struggling, and
I need to know what to do.
- Eric?
- Yeah.
First of all, the,
in photography, there's--
- [Randy] Excuse me,
I apologize because you know,
I do photography,
video, and websites.
But more photography and video.
- What do you want to
happen, before Eric answers it?
Like what do you want to happen?
Do you have a side job,
do you have a regular job?
Is this your side job?
- [Randy] No, no, no,
this is all I've wanted to do
I used to do club flyers,
so my friend used to,
he used to own the club by
the street, he got shut down.
And after doing
club flyers for awhile,
I realized I hated flyers.
So I got into--
- Don't blame him
- [Randy] I really
hate doing flyers.
So I decided to do
photography and videography,
it comes easier to me,
and if you check out my work,
you actually
messaged me back one time.
And it's really good, I'm
not one to toot my own horn,
but a lot of people like it.
But not enough
to sustain a living.
What I really want to happen
out of this, is a roadmap.
Because I've
actually looked for a mentor,
not in
photography, video aspect,
but on the
business side of that stuff,
because like, I was
transitioning to marketing.
- Do you think that,
do you think you need
a business
partner that understands
how to do the business part,
and that you're the creative?
- [Randy] There's not
enough upside
for them to come in,
and I live at
a local college down the street.
- Sounds like an artist.
- [Randy] Even for
the internships,
they'll like,
they'll learn what I teach,
what I teach really well,
and then they'll just
take off on their own.
Which is great because, I
taught somebody really well
how to get to at
least where I am,
but it's not enough upside
for somebody to come
in and say hey, whatever.
- Do you love photography?
Like if you hit the
lotto this afternoon,
would you do
photography next week?
- [Randy] Would I do,
if I hit the lotto,
I would, and I'm
at the point where--
- Tell the truth.
- [Randy] Huh?
- Tell me the truth
about this lotto question.
Five million dollars.
- [Randy] Yes, if
I won five million dollars,
they invest in what
you know, Warren Buffet,
and you said it yourself, I
can only invest in what I know,
I'd be stupid to throw my
money into something else.
So yes, it'd be
photography and videography.
I'd love to build a
building beside you.
I understand your concept of
looking to build a building
and not worrying
about everybody else,
not destroying
everybody else's building.
I'd be up under
you somewhere else.
I'm not saying I'm gonna
be the next Gary Vaynerchuck
because I don't
have enough energy.
Because I pray,
but for the love of god
I do not understand how
you're not on self meds,
Jesus Fucking Christ, you
have a shit ton of energy.
I'm really sick of it
- I do.
- [Randy] You've got to
tell me how you do it.
I don't know if it's
the Russian Jewish thing,
I don't know, either way.
My idea is that photography
and videography by itself
is not enough, considering
the saturation of the market
to actually sustain a living.
So I started to put my
photography and videography
in places where it
could be more useful,
i.e. the marketing side.
This is what this
picture can do for you,
versus here's a nice picture.
You're like, oh I'll just put it
on my Facebook on my Instagram,
and then hope
they some attraction.
- What's his name?
- [Randy] That's what
I've been doing,
and I've been talking to people.
I just talked to a lady
who has a younger--
- Hey Randy, Ran, Ran
First of all, your energy
excites me (group laughter)
so I think you
have so many, listen
let's let, you know
I kinda let you go here
just for kind of like
show, to be very frank,
let's pull this back in.
So you're
trying to make a living
creating for clients,
is that correct?
- [Randy] Absolutely.
- How much time do you spend
trying to get new clients?
And don't bullshit me
Randy, because I will hang up.
How much time every
day, do you spend DMing,
do you spend creating a
brochure and hanging it,
or putting it on somebody,
I'm gonna remind everybody,
me printing flyers and
going to the Short Hills Mall
and putting it on people's
cars, because I had no money.
Everybody thinks
it's easy, once it like,
no, no we all
start out at zippo.
Like, how much
time are you spending
trying to get
clients, for real, daily?
Don't bullshit
me, don't bullshit me.
- [Randy] I'm spending
two hours doing it,
because I have so much content
that I have to get out.
- So what are you doing?
- [Randy] What am I doing?
I'm more so stuck
Photoshopping which I--
- No, no, no, no, no.
On your two hours a
day of trying to sell,
what are you actually doing?
- [Randy] I'm
sitting on the computer.
I mean, what do you...
- No, I'm asking
you in detail, brother.
- [Randy] What's my
day to day look like?
- No!
One more time, you told me
that you spend two hours a day
trying to sell and
get clients, correct?
- [Randy] Oh, what do
I do during the selling.
I go to the
clients that I already have
and I ask them to, you
know, their hair salons,
again, the yoga studio,
see if they have clients
that'll fit my
profile versus cold calling.
- Yeah, so I think that you
are not a natural salesperson.
I think that you need to get
very comfortable around
cold calling, cold DM'ing,
emailing websites
that are local,
and driving for an
hour up and down main street
and knocking on doors
because that's
your issue right now.
You need to grab business.
It's not gonna come to you.
The end.
- [Randy] Alright, thanks.
- You're welcome, my man.
Good!
- And that's tough
'cause he's a starving artist
and there's
millions of them out there.
- One more, let's
get one more call.
- It's tough.
You've got to build your brand,
you've gotta build
the value proposition,
and you have to hustle.
- Yeah, I mean
look, it's super hard.
This is being in
the creative business.
He wants to have a business.
The problem with a lot of people
when they want
to have a business
is they don't
want the business part.
- The hard work.
- They wanna do the,
and by the way, it's hard
work to create the art,
it's hard work to be handy,
and some people
are great plumbers,
it doesn't mean that they
should have a plumbing
business that they own.
They should go work for somebody
and be the most
valuable plumber.
The craft is
separate from the business.
- [Korrina] Hello?
- Korrina, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're on
#AskGaryVee with Erik Wahl.
- [Korrina] Oh my God!
You have to be
kidding me right now!
- You made it, Korrina!
- [Korrina] Oh my God,
that is awesome!
- What's your question?
- [Korrina] Okay, my
question is if you have
too much passion
to do too many things,
like for instance, like
you have too many things,
like right now you do so much,
like you just don't
like that you have the--
- Yeah, you've got to many
things that you want to do.
- [Korrina] Exactly, yeah.
- How do you pick one?
- [Korrina] Correct, yes.
- Pick one!
(group laughter)
- [Korrina] So that's
the only advice?
Okay.
- Erik, what do you have?
I mean, this is my
most common asked question.
"Gary, I have 11 passions,
"how do I choose the right one
to build my business around?"
- I've got 11 passions as well.
I pour my time and energy into
the ones that I'm best at,
and that make money,
and then I keep the
other ones as side projects
that I will tend to as hobbies
until I can actually
turn them into something
either that I'm very good at
or that I can commoditize
and make money at,
and so, yeah.
- Korrina, I think
this is a humongous excuse
by the majority of people
that they have so
many different things
that they are passionate about,
as an excuse to not actually
put in the 15 hours a
day against something.
I really mean that, and I don't
know if that's your issue,
but I'm saying that because
a lot of people are watching,
and I wanna get to
this once and for all.
No joke, flip a fucking coin.
Write all your different
passions on a dartboard
and throw the dart,
like, just pick one.
I love when people are like,
"Gary, I love
them all so equally."
I go, "Great, then
there should be no concern."
The other things is if you're
trying to decide between two,
when you flip the coin,
a funny thing happens.
Your heart will tell you,
your brain will tell you
which one you actually wanna do.
- And Korrina, this is,
the fact that you have 11 things
that you're super pumped about,
I think that's awesome.
There's a lot of people out
there listening or watching
that are trying to find what
they're passionate about.
They don't know,
they're trying to seek money
or financial security.
The fact that you have so
many things to choose from
is a blessing that
you get to pick one
and not try and find
something in the world.
I think that's awesome.
- [Korrina] Alright,
that's awesome.
That was all my questions,
thank you guys for calling me.
This is like a really cool
experience--
- Korrina, don't
leave yet, I got a question.
- [Korrina] Go ahead, yeah.
- Which passion are
you gonna pick right now?
- [Korrina] My passion, I'm
probably gonna be a trader.
I wanna do penny stock trading.
I am also really passionate,
like I have a great
charisma with people,
so I'd actually like to just
get in on modeling right now,
'cause I do that,
so, my main one is--
- Wait a minute,
we're deciding between modeling
and penny stock trading?
(group laughter)
This is amazing! Do both!
- Korrina, if there's
anything that I can do
to talk you out of penny
stock or day trading--
- How can she find oyu?
- She can't find...
How can she find me?
- Yeah, like email you where
or hit you up on Twitter where?
If you're gonna agree
to help her, let's do it.
- Korrina, hit me up on
Instagram or Twitter @erikwahl
and send me a note
and I'll respond to you,
but I would--
- Korrina, great news, he's
gonna turn you into a model.
He's gonna talk
you outta penny stock!
- There you go, there you go.
Future modeling
career, congratulations!
- What's that?
- [Andy] That
question really remind me
of your Jason Calacanis rant.
- Yeah, I agree.
Alright, so this is like the
big moment of the episode.
So this is insane.
That's right, thank you.
I'm giving this away
because this is so sick.
And just like, I just...
To be very frank, I
kinda want it for myself,
but here's why I
wanna give it away:
I'm so convinced
in your value prop
and my belief of like
what this is gonna
be worth to one of,
so you've gotta
come and pick it up.
This is the weird thing.
So, like, I'm not
shipping it, I decided,
and so if you live in
Seattle and you win this,
come and visit me.
I'll high five you.
We're gonna pick one person
from the comments randomly,
but you have gotta answer
Erik's question of the day.
As a guest, you get to
ask the question of the day,
could be any question,
and one of you randomly,
in Facebook, or
Instagram, or YouTube,
one of those three
places, will win this...
How long did
this take you to make?
- That took me
a couple of hours,
but that's just a
box that I shipped.
And before we get to
far, I just wanna explain
that number one, I don't
sell any of my art anywhere,
so you can't buy it anywhere,
but I'm also into
value proposition,
so whoever calls in,
or whatever India sets up
is gonna get this,
but I also wanted to
throw this into that box.
So this is...
I was talking about the thinker.
This is the clouds and dirt,
this is the hard work,
this is the heavy
lifting and the thinking,
so not either or, it's yes and.
It's the spark and the grind,
so that goes inside that box.
- Okay, so
actually, should I ship it?
I should probably ship it.
We're gonna ship it.
So what is the
question of the day, my friend?
- Okay, so what I do is I,
since I don't
sell any of my artwork,
I hide it all over the world.
I hide pieces of
artwork like this
and then I tweet it
out in what are called
art drop treasure hunts,
and the first person
to find it on social media
gets to keep it,
and so with something
like this, I wanna know
from whatever city you're at,
what city would you like me to
hide a piece of artwork from?
Whatever gets the most response
is where I'll be aiming
to hide the next piece of art
for art drop.
- Erik, also, I
wanna wrap up with this.
Tell everybody
where they can find you.
Obviously, you
mentioned your Instagram,
but video blog, the
books, like what's...
- My website,
theartofvision.com.
Let's link that up.
(bell rings)
- Yeah, all of
my social's on there.
Because of you, I have
become fluent in Snapchat
the last year,
Instagram stories,
so I'm kind of
new to social media,
but I'm building
my plane as I fly it.
Learning the game
like everyone else.
- I love you, buddy.
- Thank you, pal.
- It's really good
to have you on the show.
- Pleasure being here.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)